hello everybody and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and I remember a time it must
have been like 20 years ago
by now oh my goodness I was a
postdoctoral fellow doing research at
the Institute for Theoretical Physics at
UC Santa Barbara and in fact I was not
doing research at the moment I was just
wandering through one of the local
bookstores and I saw this kid he
couldn't have been more than 9 or 10
years old and he found a book and his
eyes lit up
and he got the book he ran over to his
mom it was Christmas shopping season and
the kid says to his mom he says mom mom
mom look we got to get this for Dad
it's the elegant universe he'll love it
it's about string theory and that was
the moment when I knew that super string
theory or just string theory for short
had entered the popular imagination in
large part thanks to Brian Greene's
excellent book the elegant universe and
the Nova TV special that followed it
which is a weird thing to have a theory
of quantum gravity or a theory of
everything which is perhaps what string
theory could be to be out there in the
public debated right not just you know
told to people and I go ha that's
interesting people out there on the
streets have really strong opinions
about string theory some love it some
are very disdainful of it that's a weird
state of being for a speculative highly
technical theory in theoretical physics
for some reason string theory captures
the imagination one of my fellow
postdocs at the ITP back in those days
was Clifford Johnson who is today's
guest on the mindscape podcast
Clifford is an official card-carrying
string theorist he's written many papers
on various different aspects of string
theory
he's even authored a book called D
branes D brains are part of the string
theory toolbox and it's a highly
technical book I do not necessarily
encourage you to buy it unless you are a
professional physicist I do encourage
you to buy Clifford's more recent book
called simply the dialogues it is a
graphic novel that Clifford both wrote
the text for and illustrated it's a
novel about people talking about science
talking about physics and suggesting the
idea that sitting over coffee and
talking about science is something we
should all be doing that's an idea that
I'm extremely sympathetic with so mostly
today we'll be talking about string
theory where
came from why physicists invented it why
so many physicists so many very very
smart cookies had become incredibly
entranced by string theory what is the
origin of some of the criticisms of
string theory out there and the state of
the field today
so let's go
[Music]
Clifford Johnson welcome to the
mindscape podcast pleasure now you're a
physicist theoretical physicist and a
string theorist I know some string
theorists as soon as you describe them
as a string theorist they say no no
that's not what I am I'm this other
thing so like how do you label yourself
I suppose string theory takes up a lot
of my time or at least a lot of the
things I work on have their origins in
the string theory context and yes I'm
probably one of those who pushes back
against being called a string theorist I
think maybe the issue is that where we
like to be defined by the questions
we're working on rather than the tools
were using to answer those questions
there's not a technology-driven
exactly knowledge drift right right yeah
and so but nevertheless there have been
strings in your papers you right right I
mean sort of what fraction of the papers
you've actually written let's say in the
last ten years have been about string
theory one way or the other
oh good probably in some sense probably
1999 okay to them so we're not gonna
quibble about so what is what is string
theory and why should we care about it
that's probably another thing you hear
lots of different answers from different
string theorists i I tend to think of
string theory as primarily our best shot
right now at understanding a theory of
quantum gravity the whole the old
problem of of trying to understand how
to put together quantum physics and and
gravity and one of the things about
string theory that it's very tantalizing
is that it seems within within the way
it does that it also gives you a chance
of describing all the other forces of
nature that we know of as well and
that's something that distinguishes
string theory between from other
approaches to quantum gravity yeah there
are other approaches to quantum gravity
that regardless of what you think of
them they and
you know and how successful they are
they they really do seem to be mostly
just a framework that is to do with the
gravity and the quantum and not much
else although you know discoveries may
be made yeah you can always learn things
but what does quantum mean what does
gravity mean why is it a whole thing to
get them together shouldn't it be easy
now
veteran mindscape listeners have
listened to Carl over well we talked
about these things but that comes from a
very different place than string theory
but the motivation is similar yeah
the motivation is really very much to do
with our understanding of the observed
and you know observed universe which is
that you you will be pushed into regimes
where the quantum and the gravitational
inevitably have to talk to each other so
so to take a step back the quantum stuff
is is traditionally to do with the rules
that seem to apply for the very very
small that the the devices we use
computers phones things like that they
all use the rules of quantum mechanics
to move fundamental particles like the
electron around and you know you can use
it to to to make cool things and and
understand how atoms work the structure
of matter things like that and that
seems to be all about the very small
more or less but then there's this other
regime which is to do with astrophysics
and cosmology and so on and so forth
which is to do with whether the dominant
physics seems to be about gravity and
Einstein taught us how to understand
that sort of physics with with what's
called general relativity and it's all
to do with the curvature of space-time
which you may have you may have heard of
and whereas the description of quantum
stuff seems to be more in terms of
fundamental particles interacting with
each other in various ways and so
they're very very different pictures but
these pictures get driven together when
you realize that for example the
universe is expanding the universe is
expanding it's observable fact and if
you run that backwards if you go to
earlier epochs of the universe
in some sense the gravitational stuff
that dominates the shape of the universe
has to has to be understood in terms of
the particle physics type stuff the
small stuff because the scales on which
the physics is happening are those same
scales there's very small scales I
talked about so the the the the the
quantum physics has to talk to the
gravitational physics in ways that we we
don't we don't know yet because we don't
have a theory of quantum gravity that we
know works for nature string theory is
so sorry just to get it just so as a
relatively practical matter as these
things go what you're saying is if we
want to understand things like the Big
Bang or presumably black holes we need
both quantum mechanics and gravity at
once and we don't yet happens yeah in
fact I was gonna get two black holes
that's another region where when you
when you when you think of the black
hole as a as a thing that pops out of
for example worrying about gravity
you you end up with famously this thing
called the black hole horizon which is
sort of this one way membrane this place
after which you passed you cannot go get
go go back out and that's the famous
some black hole horizon it turns out
when you apply quantum physics to that
no matter what the size of the black
hole is it turns out quantum physics
doesn't like to play that game of
one-way barriers and it tells you that
there's actually a mechanism by which
quantum mechanically that one-way
barrier will will generate ways of stuff
getting back out that'll actually leak
energy and mass from the black hole and
make the black hole begin to shrink and
ultimately in principle the black hole
would would would disappear and that
leads you into a whole bunch of
paradoxes that famously do to people
like Stephen Hawking who came up with
that shrinking mechanism that tell you
that you need to understand again this
quantum and gravity stuff better in
order to understand the fate of black
hole
in some sense the fate of our
understanding of quantum mechanics
itself and so there are all sorts of
interesting issues that begin to not go
away and become more and more annoying
if you don't have a theory of quantum
gravity to explain them so at some very
simple level of principle the world is
quantum mechanical the world has gravity
so of course you need quantum gravity
but you're saying also as a relatively I
keep when I say straightforward or
down-to-earth but it's really not
because we're talking about the Big Bang
of black holes but as a concrete matter
there are phenomena in our universe that
can't be understood without
understanding quantum gravity absolutely
there are ways just to just just to blur
it a little bit there are always people
do propose that maybe there are some get
out roses and you could have gravity in
a quantum mechanical world without it
being quantum but that in some ways can
often end you end you up in a place
that's harder to explain than just
quantizing the thing that's just gonna
end in tears
so that's fine and probably the
motivation people are willing to accept
but now why in the world would we say
the right way to address this is to
replace particles with little zum
substring if indeed that's what we're
doing in string theory well so the
answer is that no one can tell you a
good principled reason why you do that
it really was discovered by accident
that that is at all the right thing to
do or a right thing to do because we
don't know if it's the right thing to do
when you when you think from a particle
physics perspective about what a quantum
theory of gravity should look like or a
quantum theory of any interaction any
interaction between objects the particle
physics perspective is that there is a
particle whose job it is to communicate
the effects of that force and so the
famous you know the electromagnet let
your magnetism that force the force that
that governs all of chemistry and you
know so is responsible for electricity
and magnetism and things like that that
is communicated by the exchange of
photons of the particle we're very
familiar with it's the particle of light
and and so every different kinds of
fourth the nuclear forces have their own
exchange particles and you can actually
work out what the properties of the
exchange for should be for gravity if
you did have a quantum theory of gravity
and it's called the graviton the
graviton yes and everyone always says
we'll have you discovered gravitons yet
and I say no and we never will because
they're too hard to detect but the
principles of quantum mechanics and
general relativity convinced us yeah
there are something called graviton yeah
and so what so what you could start
doing is you could write down a theory
that is a you know interacting gravitons
and and you can just write down the
properties of the graviton how they
should interact on general principles
and the theory just resists making sense
on its own for reason you know various
technical reasons which we don't need to
go into it just stops working pretty
pretty soon you trying to calculate
anything sensible with it completely for
other reasons people were playing around
with the idea of what if you were not
looking at fundamental particles
interacting quantum mechanically but you
were looking at loops of string and what
are we thinking now sorry when were they
actually back in the 60s and the late
60s going into the 70s for reasons to do
with trying to understand nuclear
physics they were thinking about this
there are actual mechanisms by which you
in nuclear interactions you effectively
make these things that look like strings
they call flux tubes and and then they
move like real physical objects and can
interact and split and join and things
like that so people thought it would
actually be useful to write down a
theory just in principle what would such
a thing look like and if you so if you
work it all out
it actually works rather nicely and out
pops something very interesting which
actually at the time was a bug yeah in
the whole this problem right which is
that these these these loops of string
tend to want to join their ends and
become little closed loops of string
where the loops you were thinking of the
starter just line sack yeah there were
sort of lines that they had ends at
there actually the fundamental particles
called quarks that very
and nuclear physics would be joined by
these these these things called flux
tubes and they'd be the description and
it was thought to be a candidate for the
theory of the strong interactions that
bind these quarks together and but there
were there were mechanisms by which
these strings just the theory tells you
that they have to be allowed to do that
to join those ends and become loops of
string that are closed and if you if you
if you follow that you find that those
loops are string the different
vibrations they can do the most basic
vibration if you if you sort of squint
and don't realize it's a string it's
sort of it's small enough that it looks
like a particle it looks just like that
that particle that you would have
associated with gravity what's called a
spin to massless boson the graviton to
graviton and sorry I wanted you know
because I think that to the people who
don't do this for a living it's kind of
a remarkable thing mmm the theory forces
it on yeah you invented the theory yeah
and it forces you to do something you
didn't want to do that how often is that
happening in physics exactly so so it's
you often get requirements of the theory
has to be consistent and you realize oh
I forgot this thing so I need to add
that in or I don't have the right number
of this bit compared you know the right
ingredients weren't put together in the
right way and then and then you're done
one of the remarkable things and I
talked about this very fact quite a bit
which is that it's unusual historically
and I think has has few such striking
precedents that you write down a theory
and it says I'm going to work but here's
a list of demands for why you know what
what I needed order to work and that
list of demands and sends you off in
this completely different direction and
one of them was that it has to if you
write down these these these these loops
of string it has to have this the spin-2
particle that people then realize later
on with the graviton which was the
reason it was a problem is because there
was no such particle in the in the
strong interactions described they
didn't want that so it looked like a big
fail
and it was but the particle the the
theory did some other things as well
really unprecedent is it says it doesn't
actually work very well if you try and
have it in our three spatial plus one
time dimensions it actually starts
telling you that actually I'm gonna work
really well if I work in actually
started out being in 26 dimensions and
then they're better versions of it that
work in ten dimensions which is another
obvious bug so theory has a very strong
mean representation and they have a lot
of demand exactly or they get to work
right oh 26 dimensional space-time and
you need to have gravity in it yeah and
weaker Minds than ours would have said
well let's do something else
exactly and well not only let's do
something else but something else did
come along a better theory for
describing the strong interactions
called quantum chromodynamics came along
and and so people were very happy to not
have to deal with this list of demands
it turns out that there were some people
who thought this was really interesting
notably John Schwarz and Rorschach they
said hey maybe this theory is good for
something else these bugs are actually a
feature and we've been using this thing
for something else and this is a great
example of something that I actually
think is really important in not just in
physics but generally speaking if people
are working on a thing as as you know
with as much integrity as possible just
trying to do an interesting thing and
develop an idea it may often turn out
that it's not necessarily good for the
thing they thought it was going to be
for but it often can have uses elsewhere
and and certainly in science we see that
a lot in various other ways of many
ideas that get recycled in various parts
and have their home in places other than
where they were first invented and
certainly string theory seems to be an
example of that yeah it's definitely
motivation for letting smart people
pursue their interests and what they
think is interesting without an
immediate obvious payoff right right in
the quarterly report right because we're
gonna eventually get someplace right so
yeah so John Schwarz my Caltech
colleague joel scherk who passed away a
few years ago
as I recall so they said look gravity
exists
string theory seems to predict gravity
so what did they do about this
difficulty about making a match on to
the real world
so they they then said well maybe this
this whole string theory thing is a
theory of gravity the the the higher
dimensional part is this is a suggestion
that there are there are large
observable dimensions than in which we
live that the three spatial dimensions
plus time and and and they and and and
others that came after them it came up
with mechanisms by which the extra
dimensions that the string theory
suggests would need to be there for the
consistency of the theory turn out to be
internal degrees of freedom extra extra
decorations that that the physics has so
it looks to us if you write it the right
way it looks to us like a three
dimensional theory plus some extra
labels if you like that some would
describe as positions in these higher
dimensional spaces and others would say
it's just different flavors of particle
and things like that and indeed that
that you can work out models if you're
if you're a string phenomenologist
someone who built models of string
theory that are attempts at representing
our real world our observed world there
are very understood well understood
mechanisms by which the the higher
dimensions of the string theory end up
reflects re they end up making
themselves known for example by being
some of the unexplained patterns that we
actually do see in the standard model of
physics oh so if you work out the the
the list of particles that we've
discovered they assemble themselves into
some very interesting your electron in
the muon and the Tau and all neutrinos
that you know their their their various
families of particles that that that
don't really have any explanation the
the standard model of particle physics
describes it but does not explain where
those patterns come from one thing that
higher dimensions can do is in fact give
you reasons why those patterns exist
they turn out yeah so there's we have to
get rid of we went from 26 I think we
need to mention 10 that's the endpoint
good we had to get rid of a lot of
dimensions and roughly speaking we curl
them up and do a little tiny ball yeah
that's basically that we that's one way
of doing it it's not the only way but
that's the way people often describe it
yeah
off the shelf yeah yeah standard package
way of getting rid of the extra
dimensions but there's more than one way
of doing that and therefore there
there's different there's one string
theory or well we'll get to that too
maybe but there's not that many flavors
of string theory at the most fundamental
level but there are many ways that it
could manifest itself as three plus one
dimensional space-time yeah the the
mechanism by which those those those
dimension those hidden dimensions are
become hidden the shape of that space as
it were it seems to have many many
choices and even amongst the choices
that end up resembling to a sort of
first first pass our world there are
many many choices with within that from
a pragmatic perspective that ends up
looking like you have a theory with a
lot of unexplained parameters right and
and so that that's that's one of the
things we're still struggling with in
string theory is that really true or
have we not understood the theory well
enough to to see how to fix those
parameters and the answer is we don't
know yeah it's very hard to do
experiments right you're talking about
energy scales far beyond what we can
probe at the Large Hadron Collider for
example yeah yeah the the would be nice
if there was experimental guidance to
help us fix those parameters and and it
could be you know the pessimistic view
is that those parameters aren't fixed
and you do some experiment to to figure
out what those parameters are and
you know there's just any number of
different ways of designing a string
theory to fit those parameters and so
you lose predictive ability and you know
that's a big discussion yeah I mean as I
recall there was a hope back in the 80s
I know that the theory came online in
the 60s and it was developed but only by
a small number of people in the 70s and
it exploded in popularity in the
eighties yeah and there was hope that it
would be unique right like the string
theory you just predict the ratio of
masses of all these different particles
and so as of 2018 that seems to be
unlikely right cetera it seems to be the
it seemed it's the best way of putting
it I would say it hasn't come true yet
and well unlikely says something more
than it hasn't come true yet it's
talking about you know whether or not it
will come true the answer is we don't
know but so the question is what are the
prospects for the theory is is it that
there's some mechanism that will teach
us that there's a unique answer that
string theory will will will produce and
I think no one has or feels that were
necessarily close to a good idea that
will tell us if there's some big
principle we're missing but clearly the
way you're phrasing this you're still
holding out the prospect I think it's a
it is a possibility that that old idea
good work in some shape or form my gut
feeling says that we're by time we
figure out something like that we may
not even be doing something that that's
even recognizably string theory anymore
good right we'll get to that but first
we skipped over the whole 10 dimensional
yes you said 26 I said 26 Ryan green
tells me it's tender back yeah are you
guys disagreeing oh no no it's not it's
not this new math at all it really is a
16 to be understood again depending upon
how you think about it there are there
are there different ways of going from
that 26 to 10 but the short version of
the story is is that the theory that's
26 dimension was really the
thing you write down and you you
basically in nature in particle physics
there are two broad kinds of particle
the things called fermions things called
bosons it has to do with what's called
the spin of these particles and but
roughly speaking the stuff most
everything that you think of as a matter
particle is actually a Fermi on it has
what's called spin 1/2 or some
fractional spin sorry some multiple of
1/2 yes yes thank you yeah I wasn't sure
whether or not right now so so so yes
electrons quarks and things like that
whereas the particles they exchange that
give rise to force that we recognize as
force exchange particles they're
actually bosons so the original string
theories that were written down that a
twenty six dimensional are our bosonic
string theory is they just have that one
kind but nature has these two kind so if
you start trying to write down theories
that have both kinds of particles
fermions and bosons as an attempt to
understand nature what you find is that
the theory again doesn't work very well
unless you work in ten dimensions so the
twenty six dimensional theory has forces
but not matter if you like yes and if we
want both yeah ten dimensions seems to
be the way to go yeah and so and that
was that was what triggered the big
explosion what's called the first
superstring revolution which was so John
Schwarz and Michael Greene found that
the the things that were we're that were
failing to work when you had both bosons
and fermions in the theory
go away precisely in ten dimensions they
they there's a there's a big internal
consistency thing called an anomaly
which you need which comes up in quantum
theories when you have fermions
and those go away precisely in those
dimensions for very very beautiful and
interesting from a technical perspective
reasons which meant that people really
began to pay attention because it was it
was it was a it was a consistency that
that was so so delicate and and and and
and so intricately put together they
told you something very deep was going
on so in some sense it's again the
theory is telling you what his demands
are like there wasn't it wasn't even
obvious that it would work in any number
of defendants yeah and this is where the
word super yeah it's attached to super
spring riot II right right and that's
because the the presence of fermions and
bosons actually have to come in a
certain kind of balance it turns out
there's a symmetry relating the bosons
and fermions which got called
supersymmetry and that was a that was a
kind of symmetry that had not been
thought of before that actually was
discovered in the context of of string
theory and and turns out to be again in
its own right very interesting and we
can probably talk about that too so
supersymmetry was combined with string
theory and so the term super string
theory was born some of the some of the
the real sort of big shots in the field
started paying attention then and
started making some remarkable
contribution so famously with that's
when Witten came into the field ed
Witten and and started showing how you
these internal spaces where this hidden
six dimensions could six plus four is
ten those hidden six dimensions would be
had had certain important properties
that he was able to characterize and and
and then it turned out to lead to an
explosion of activity in mathematics as
well because those spaces turn out to
have very important mathematical
properties this is this is actually the
birth of string theory as this this
other thing which is a unifier of ideas
in in theoretical physics and
mathematics and and some other fields
because it turns out that the those
tight consistencies
to generate new knowledge about the
mathematical possibilities that you can
have and then yet another thing that the
theory ended up telling us that we
didn't put into it is that string theory
is not just a theory of strength yeah
there's other stuff why didn't we just
stop with this drink exactly and so that
historically that's really interesting
because people were asking that question
very early on well if you go from points
to lines why stop there yeah and people
and people who are coming up with all
kinds of reasons why you should stop
there which were not very well motivated
but mostly due to you know failure of
imagination and no good evidence that
the other stuff would work I remember in
the early 90s being in a lecture hall at
a summer school and a student asked well
why aren't there the new dimensional
membrane it's an a extremely famous
string theorist whose name I will
suppress was extremely scoffing of the
idea that we should go anywhere beyond
string yeah I I remember being in some
of those rooms and hearing some of those
answers and questions as well and what
actually happened is the the the the the
theory began to cry out for the
inclusion of those sorts of things
itself so there were there were hints
there were hints by a number of people
working but I think some of the most
compelling hints were done in this
beautiful paper by by paul townsend and
chris hall and and then edward witten
very famously actually at a conference
that was here at USC where I'm based in
1995 put it all together and triggered
what we now call the second super string
where I was a revolution the idea was
that if you start considering regimes
which are if you like called strongly
interacting regimes where the strings
are not just interacting with each other
weakly but really really strongly you
you you start going into getting into
difficulty session this actually happens
more broadly than just in in string
theory or particle physics what have you
typically anything we calculate in
theoretical physics
is in a regime usually starts out in a
regime with us called perturbation
theory where you start out with the
three where nothing is interacting and
then you add money to particles going
right by yeah that's never pop yeah
indeed that's easy we can write that
yeah and and so you get that all right
and then you go okay now let's get these
guys to interact but we do it first very
weakly we say that it's it's it's the
non interacting theory plus some small
Corrections the interaction tiny
glancing blows yeah and actually that
turns out to be incredibly powerful much
of theoretical physics is based on just
doing that but there are regimes again
you driven you often driven to them by
the necessity to understand experiments
and things like that where you actually
need to understand what regimes where
those constituents are interacting with
each other strongly and if you ask that
question about string theory you you
you've you find that a lot of the
descriptions that you first thought of
in terms of strings interacting with
each other are not very good
descriptions at all and they begin to
break down in a way that leaves you
wondering what to do and so one
possibility is that eventually you just
find sure we're lucky maybe in some
regime and we find a strong couple
description and and and then you work
out the answers and you're done
what actually happened in this case is
that we started understanding at first
in these extremes where if you if you
try and understand strong coupling but
sort of at some intermediate level the
whole theory looks like a mess the basic
the basic players begin to it's hard to
tell who's what you you lose track of
who the basic players are the basic
degrees of freedom as we would say
technically it's not clear what they are
anymore but if you if you just in your
mind extrapolate to to an extremely
strongly coupled regime the theory
begins to simplify again strangely and
it turns out that there's a way of
rewriting all of that horrible mess in
terms of a weakly coupled theory again
which sounds bizarre but it says that
what you can idea what you can do is
identify new players in this in this in
this horrible mathematical mess but if
you describe things from their
perspective the theory simplifies again
so it's like if two people have never
met
they are just individuals and we treat
them that way if they are long fallen in
love and are married then they're a
couple let me free them that way but
it's when they know each other a little
bit and there's sexual tension that
things are complicated and we're not
quite sure how to treat them right but
if you go to the other extreme and I'm
trying to see where this analogy is
going to go wondering what the what the
duo weekly shuffled it misanthropic
lipid only but indeed yes it's hard to
sort of pull these things apart that you
know the the whole is greater than the
sum of its parts but finishing the story
what we found is and and this is this is
something that is sort of where I came
in in terms of that stage in my career
where I was very interested in strongly
coupled problems the you you find in
some of these regimes that the new
players sometimes are strings again but
in some cases they're not strengths
they're actually extended objects a
higher dimensional membranes so they
either have their rather like a sheet of
paper which is a two-dimensional
membrane or higher dimensions and
because you have ten dimensions you you
have many many different possibilities
and it turns out when you when you sit
down and work it all out
basically all the possibilities are in
play the full description of string
theory is not as a theory of strings at
all it's a it's it's a theory of all
different all possibilities of extended
objects interacting in some way it just
so happens strings are privileged by
being the things that carry because of
that that closed loop that carry the
quantum of gravity but there's more than
just gravity going on right and this is
relationship between weakly coupled
strings and strongly coupled other
things that may be strings or other
things this is an example of a duality
yeah so that the phrase duality is used
all over our culture of course in this
context you know it has some of that
same character which is that there there
are two or more aspects to this ways of
looking at this this this whole thing
and so do a Latina saying there's some
physics and in it one way of looking at
it it it can be described in terms of
interacting strings but there's a
different way of looking at it in which
it may be interacting membranes or an
interacting set of strings that are very
different from the other perspective and
and so these dual natures are considered
both essential to understanding what the
whole thing is so it's one theory that
we can talk about in two different ways
yes yes and you know in some ways well
actually I would say it differently I
would say it's it's it's one set of
phenomena and we have different theories
that describe parts of those phenomena
that sort of fit together in a patchwork
to give us an understanding of the whole
thing is it sometimes I say tell me if
I've been making mistake here sometimes
I say it's that we have two different
classical limits of the same underlying
quantum theory happy with that sure sure
okay yeah maybe you know it's fine I
mean there can be other there can be
other limits of a sort of intrinsically
quantum yeah this is good enough all
right yeah enough for podcast yeah I
think there's another dual podcast in
which I did do a podcast much more
strongly coupled in this one and this is
all part of this whole business with the
brain mm-hmm
pran es yes that's constructed from
membranes you know we have one brains
are just strings mm-hmm
two brains three brains for brains five
grains etc and this all came in the
1990s so the early 80s were the first
superstring revolution the 1990s were
the second super evolution and the most
famous do
them all came on the scene in the 1990s
thanks to one multivator yes so with uh
with in with so 1995 was the was the was
the revolution where we realized that
brains were were crucial and lots of the
many different string theories the five
what the four different string theories
that we did that with that we did know
about were actually parts of this big
hole and people were bandying about this
chain that the whole thing should be
called m-theory but no one knew what m
stood for and every possible pun on the
word brain aired a paper title exactly
yeah you're responsible for some of
those puns here and but then and I will
get I will get to to to to Malthus enter
in a moment but it's worth mention that
the really key thing I would say that
stop this from all being just nice words
was that people began to find these very
very sharp computational tools that
allowed you to really handle because
previously we didn't have the technical
ability to handle the dynamics of these
high dimensional objects which is I
think why a lot of people said well they
just don't make sense because the
previous attempts just meant that it
wasn't working and so famously Joe
polchinski who sadly passed away this
year was responsible for coming up with
the technology the calculational
technology that told you at least in
some regimes how to handle these
different kinds of higher dimensional
extended obvious right and described
their shapes how they intersect it was
just an amazingly powerful technology
and just yeah cuz I know we use the word
but this is a different yes of the word
technology than some of our listeners
might be technical know-how and ability
so not it not it not a device in terms
of a physical device but a a means by
which you can calculate things and get
answers which is the the meat and drink
of the tofu of the theorists and and so
this character
relational technology then began to be
applied to many different things whether
you were interested in better models of
how to get the standard model of
particle physics out one have you but
also understanding questions about black
holes real quantum gravity questions and
so there's a whole story there but this
amazingly is happening in two years
yeah from 1995 by 1997 we have a very
nice detailed picture of of how to do a
lot of things with black holes and
string theory there's a seminal paper in
96 by Strom enger' and Vava and then
there's a host of other papers and what
was beginning to emerge was this idea
that there are there's another kind of
duality called okay well for technical
reasons called gauge gravity duality
which is that there are calculations you
could do using gravity that will teach
you things about what are called gauge
theories gauge theories or certain kinds
of particle physics type theories that
you use in particle physics to calculate
things there they don't have gravity in
them yeah that's the important thing so
this is exactly when we say gauge theory
we're not going to find what a gauge
theory is but it's a certain kind of
theory that just lives in the world
where you ignore gravity but you saw
particles interacting with each other so
the standard meat-and-potatoes as you
just said of a particle physicist a
prototype example of that is the theory
of electromagnetism that is the that is
the the the original and arguably the
best gauge theory and you know going
back to you know Maxwell's description
of electromagnetism in the in the 19th
century so you have you have this this
this powerful tool that we know works
really well for particle physics it is
still the thing we use to get the
answers right about what's coming out of
the Large Hadron Collider and
what-have-you these are gauge theories
so all the Fineman diagrams Fineman
diagrams all those things come from from
from working on gauge series so
gauge series turned out to be a key
piece of the tool that describes these
these extended objects these brains of
different kinds called d-branes that Joe
had found with collaborators anyway so
the what was beginning to emerge when
you started applying them to things like
black holes
was that there are calculations you can
do just using theories with no gravity
these geisha Aries and they will tell
you about things that have to do with
gravity and and that was unimpressive
that was really unprecedented if you
follow how string theory is built it
follows from some of those very early
things I was telling you about those
closed loops coming from the joining of
open loops and just I think we get to
catch our breath here is a lot to take
in but so we were starting with gauge
theories which is just a fancy way of
saying we're doing particle physics
without gravity okay which means because
you said before that string theory
predicts gravity these aren't even
string theories these are just particle
physics theories right yeah and we look
at them closely enough in the right
circumstances and we realize they're
secretly telling us something about
gravity even though gravity wasn't
theirs yes my blowing it is mind blowing
and and it but but it is all traceable
back to the fact that when you went bad
these things called gauge series when
you embed them in string theory which is
to say when you because string theory
contains a lot of stuff as I said coming
from the vibrations of these different
kinds of strings and what have you and
so there's some kinds of string that
when when when you describe their
vibrations and yet again you look at
them sort of far away enough the year
don't realize that they're loops a
string they just look like little
particles they will give you gauge
theories and those are really the things
the the things I referred to earlier as
open strings the strings that have ends
right and so but because string theories
tell you that sorry because the dynamics
of you know just the the laws of motion
of these things tell you that they have
to close up eventually they will tell
you if you even if you don't put it in
that they also know about gravity right
and and so it comes out of the theory at
you again that was not something we were
looking for it came out of the theory
and so so people were beginning to
understand how to handle that on a
technical level better and better and so
the idea of these dualities different
pictures you could use where sometimes
I'm studying the physics in terms of
gravitational physics or sometimes I'm
discovering I'm studying it in terms of
non gravitational physics and I can get
sometimes useful answers from both
perspectives that was beginning to
emerge and then and by late 1997 an
example of very very clean and beautiful
example of this was put forward by by
hewan maldacena
which is called that would now call the
ATSC ft correspondence and that is just
a version but a very very powerful and
sharp version of this larger picture of
this duality between gravity and gauge
shiri and so the ADRC of t
correspondence in the 80s and the CFT
are technical terms which really telling
you that I do gravity and a certain kind
of space or space-time which is actually
called anti-de sitter it basically it's
a it's a space-time that is it has a
cosmological constant it has an energy
density to the space-time that turns out
to be negative and you can write it down
and do things with it it's a model it
doesn't have necessarily anything to do
with our world it's it's a it's a place
in which you can do certain kinds of
quantum gravity calculations and that
that's always a healthy thing to be able
to do but when you do those calculations
including sometimes the you know the
pret that black holes are present they
may form they may disappear all sorts of
things they can do there's a completely
different description of that within a
theory that has no gravity in one
dimension fewer and that's an important
clue I think that we ought to get back
to in one dimension fewer which just
looks like a somewhat difficult but but
in principle possible particle physics
calculation and so this gives you this
amazing
insight into what gravity may or may not
be but it also gives you this amazing
toolbox right because one of the things
that comes along with these dualities is
that it tells you that sometimes the
easy calculations on one side of the
duality turn out to be the hard
calculation on the other side so for
pragmatic reasons we like to a letís
because usually they tell us that give
us ways of calculating things that we
normally can't get at so so there's a
piece of physics you're trying to
describe which is a really hard particle
physics computation and it tells you do
this gravity computation and you'll get
the answer or there's a really hard
gravity computation and it says do this
particle physics calculation you'll get
the answer this amazingly it gives you
insight into a whole bunch of
interesting problems that were sort of
held up for decades so let's see if we
can't make sure we understand what abs
means anti-de sitter space so tell us a
little about remind us this sense in
which it's not the real world there we
live in the real world and the real
world seems to have a positive energy in
empty space a positive cosmological
constant indeed and so the cosmological
constant what the different ways of
thinking about one way to thinking about
is that there's just some intrinsic it
just comes with the territory amount of
energy associated where if you take a
chunk of space-time and you were to look
at its energy content you would find
that it has some and there are three
possibilities it can either be positive
negative or zero even in empty space in
space space itself has this as its
energy density associated with it and so
for a long time we thought that it was
zero for for for our world and we didn't
notice any right right we didn't notice
any and theorist being theorists then
wrote many many papers saying well of
course it's zero exactly and and the so
the ops
you know so there then observations that
suggest at least that among the simplest
explanations is that our universe
actually has a small
positive cosmological constant you can
also write down the universal part
accelerating is indeed excel it's one
way of thinking about it is it really
sort of accelerates expansion of the
universe the negative cost model
constant is is the other possibility and
so like I said it doesn't necessarily
seem to have anything to do with our
universe but because of this duality I
was telling you about it tells you about
how to do calculate because calculations
in such negative cosmological constant
spaces secretly are calculating for you
strongly coupled particle physics
question right there are ways in which
people have been using that forgetting
about the whole whether or not this is
anything to do with theories of
everything or anything like that it's
just an issue of I now have this toolbox
that tells me how to do these strongly
couple calculations which are really
important for understanding things in
nuclear physics really important things
for understanding things in condensed
matter physics there are there are there
are phases of particle physics whether
it's a lots of electrons interacting
with each other and in a certain kind of
medium or whether it's the core of a
neutron star or whether it's just the
nuclei of our atoms those actually are
intrinsically strongly coupled systems
that nature tells us are there and we
can experiment on them and they have
phenomena that we don't understand in
terms of doing weakly coupled
calculations so you need a tool that can
tell you how to do some of these
strongly calpico click calculate and
there are many different kinds of tools
but among the tools are now thinking
about them in terms of these dual
theories of gravity right so I'm still
not completely convinced that we all
know what ATS is so I'm gonna okay on
this sorry fine so ad s is we say it's a
space-time with a negative Cosmo
constant no it's not like a place you
can go it's not like you know a location
in our universe this is a hypothetical
universe
that we physicists can write down the
equations for and it's basically an
empty universe except that there's a
negative energy in empty space itself
that's what that's what a anti-de sitter
space yes right yes there's a person
named de sitter yes a hundred years ago
and he invented de sitter space and now
we just changed the sign and change the
sign and a whole lot of things change
when you change that simple so exactly
and it's a this might even be dangerous
to say but maybe it's better to bring up
the confusions and fix them to pretend
that they're not there if a positive
cosmological constant accelerates things
apart
why wouldn't a negative cosmological
constant just cause the universe to rika
lapse into a Big Crunch oh that's a good
question I have to think about to think
about a good way of thinking about that
maybe the short answer is that it does
if there's other stuff yeah yeah I'm
trying to think I'm trying to think sort
of famously when you start adding when
you start adding things you will get
instabilities right I'm trying to think
in in some ways
why the pure case is still quite robust
yeah I guess there's nothing to crunch
yeah that's a good that's a good way of
putting it yeah yeah yeah so we have an
infinitely big space yeah negative
energy everywhere and you're saying that
a theory of gravity of quantum gravity
in that space is dual - which is another
way of saying is sort of physically the
same but in written in a different way
as a theory was no gravity at all in one
less dimension so if we had a
four-dimensional anti-de sitter space
that will be dual to a three dimensional
quantum field theory yeah and problems
that are hard in one theory might be
easy in the other one and vice versa and
now we have this way of taking hard
problems and mapping them onto easy
problems so this is full employment for
theoretical physicist yeah I mean
ultimately that's really all we do we
find tools for answering you know doing
cows you know being able to calculate in
various regimes and understand things
and much of the rest is you know deck
so the word holography also yes I was
gonna get to that because one of the
things it also tells us is that worrying
about the dimension of space-time itself
may be a red herring I personally think
it's this is all a clue that you know
when we start going on string theory has
this a number of dimensions and you hit
a bunch of them what have you I think
one day we'll understand that that's all
the red herring it's overrated
space-time is overrated
well what dimension itself is is is it
something that is going to be somewhat
in the eye of the beholder we already
see it in this in this context you do
these calculations in in one of these
geisha Aries so you start out for
example trying to understand certain
phenomena in three plus one dimensional
space-time you think surely that's the
right way because we live in three plus
one dimensions and you do the
calculation and it goes off the strong
coupling and you have good experimental
recent reason to want to know what the
answers are in strong coupling and then
someone comes along and says well for
that particular phenomenon here is a way
of understanding it but you've got to
work with a five dimensional theory of
gravity and now would anyone order right
and and you know you might go well
that's just nonsense or you might go I
just want something that can tell me
what the answers are and and and so you
just hold your nose it's the wrong
number of dimensions and it's the theory
of gravity which is where I started but
from a pragmatic perspective that's
telling you that you can get answers to
physical phenomena nature doesn't care
whether you label it with this number of
dimensions and whether this is gravity
or not and nature's just nature I think
that's where we're being led yeah
and that we saw that also with the as a
particles as a strings as it membranes
is what have you
Nature doesn't care and this is part of
why and I think this is the single
hardest thing for people in the public
to get as to why string theorists are so
excited I mean there's been an anti
string theory backlash there was a pro
string theory you know for laughs the
elegant universe came along people were
very very excited Nova special etc and
then they there were these books against
it and people got upset but
when you're in the trenches doing string
theory this theory that you wrote down
in the 1960s keeps pushing us in
interesting directions that we didn't
even anticipate it smells like something
right is going on and maybe that's maybe
it's not right you know it's always
possible because at the end of the day
it's going to be experiments that decide
but there are really good reasons to
think that it's not just all an accident
that all this is working out yeah not
only is it not an accident it's not that
we're being misled by you know a vocal
set of senior people what-have-you
because the point is is that this this
is this is theoretical physics you can
do those calculations and the
calculations themselves are telling you
what's going on right some some you know
some visionary senior people may tell
you to look at those calculations but
then very rapidly you get up to speed
and you see oh this really is
interesting and then for your own
reasons
depending upon your own flavor of
physics that led you to where you are
you go oh there's something really
interesting in here and and there's more
than meets the eye and and so I think
historically this is an interesting time
because I think we really are sort of
chipping away at corners of something
that I think is much larger much more
interesting and and none of us know
where it's going to go and yes but it is
certainly the case it could turn out all
to be wrong but I suspect even if it
turns out to be wrong in the sense of it
isn't good for the thing that we thought
it was going to be good for I'd be
surprised if it wasn't going to be good
for something well you made the point
that it's we develop technology in this
sense and it's it can now be applied to
problems that are other than the Big
Bang or quantum gravity right and so
give it just give us just one example
for us to fix our minds either from your
work or from somewhere else about how we
can use let's say a DSC of tea this
duality between particle physics and
gravity to do to answer some tangible
questions about physics yeah what so so
there are a number of regions where I
think a lot of the work is is is you
know just that once too
further than then then maybe sort of
qualitative in the sense that there are
kinds of behavior that you would like to
classify you'd like to understand at
least what the possibilities are that
you see in strongly coupled systems in
real experiments so people actually make
you know their I condensed matter people
people who worry about clumps of
material that where the electrons are
doing stuff in some strange way and
there's some new kind of way they behave
as a result of them interacting strongly
you'd like to understand but we're
talking about real people in real labs
there's no five dimensional yeah these
are real people in real life building
stuff that may be in your phone one day
right or or something like that and then
on the other hand there are questions to
do with the kinds of things that can
happen when you take lots of nuclear
material quarks interacting strongly and
clump them together now one example is
just nuclei themselves the nuclei of
atoms but you also have nuclear material
doing interesting things in astrophysics
you you get entire you know ten miles
across lumps of nuclear material
condense together called neutron stars
that we now actually observe them
colliding in in realization always and
that may be the place where a huge
amount of the heavy elements you know
gold famously and what-have-you actually
that we see here on earth actually came
from all of those have to do with phases
of strongly coupled matter that that we
know take place in in nature and we
don't have good descriptions of so there
are many many different kinds of
possibilities and of the the the working
with these dual theories at least help
you enumerate the kinds of possibilities
they don't get the answers right on the
nose because these systems are typically
very complicated and have many more
components and we can handle
computationally but they're there abroad
a brush stroke so you want to get right
initially like what is even what is even
possible what kinds of phases of these
different kinds of
matter exotic matter if you like can you
get and previously we had no good tools
for enumerate those phases very nicely
that's one thing that you do get out of
these out of these these kinds of
strongly coupled models so didn't I see
that you wrote a paper with neutron
stars and the titles that I mean I have
been thinking about neutron stars I plan
to write some very literally using the
the doubles we learn from string theory
to understand the neutron stars out
there yeah yeah so so some of my
earliest work was very early on when
this 80s CFT stuff came out I figured
out ways with with some colleagues of of
working out you know what the physicists
would call the phase diagram which is
essentially a diagram of the
possibilities the kinds of phases so
famously phases water it has a solid
form it has a liquid form has a gaseous
form you can actually work out the phase
diagram of water under under various
prey you know this pressure in this
temperature what form is it in so you
can work that out you need to know that
to understand water if you really claim
to understand water so you need to
understand that for nuclear physics as
well so so some of the very earliest
work was the stuff I was involved with
in showing that this in principle could
help you get the phase diagram of the
core of a neutron star right in
principle you know this was again
broad-brush Eric's because I was I was
convinced that that would be a really
great application for some of this stuff
now as I said this is broad brushstrokes
there's a lot to be done well it's been
happening really very recently which i
think is is very exciting is the whole
business of being able to calculate very
difficult quantum mechanical sorry yeah
quantum mechanical diagnostic tools as
it were in in field theories again our
colleagues in the experimental world of
various kinds want to know when these
different phases are happening or about
to happen or
to be changed from one face from another
what do you keep track off to figure out
what what you know what's going on how
do you characterize these things a lot
of these a lot of the traditional phases
of matter are typically it would be go
that we learn about in school what have
you have to do with things being driven
by very classical sorts of things that
are going on now a lot of these new
phases is driven by quantum effect it's
like oh it's harder it's harder and it's
harder to calculate yeah and so they're
very important quantity is called
entanglement that are the things that we
like to keep track we think would be
good to keep track of turns out these
are really hard things to calculate in
in in field theories outside
two-dimensional field theories where it
turns out they're tricks you can use one
of the really big things that's been
happening in the last just few years I
would say has been the explosion of
methods using gravity duels of
calculating these quantum diagnostic
things what are things like entanglement
entropy and various cousins of
entanglement entropy and you use these
now as as the things you track to see
when the degrees of freedom are
rearranging themselves and a new phase
is coming up that's going to be hugely
important I think in as an application
on the quantum side but then we've also
been turning it on its head because I
think people are beginning to realize
that keeping track of quantum degrees of
freedom maybe a more made arguably
fundamental way of keeping track of
what's going on on the space-time side
what's what's what's gravity actually
doing right and and so it's becoming
also important in understanding what
truly are black holes in string theory
what and and hopefully what truly black
holes are quantum mechanically and Buzz
balls are in the news the political that
IP fuzzy balls of string yeah so so this
is again something is hugely important I
think the the going back to 1996 where
we embedded black holes and string
theory
now with the new knowledge that strings
as more than strings it's all of these
other kinds of things and we realized
that we could understand a number of the
fundamental things that beckon Stein and
Hawking had said about black holes and
quantum mechanics back in the 70s we
understood how to actually prove some of
those things they said in in 1996 and
that was started with straw meter and
vaster a beautiful paper and then what
happens that we sort of forgot some of
the lessons that we learned from that
paper and and some of the follow-up
papers and and then we started
revisiting black holes and quantum
mechanics again water black holes
quantum information paradox and and
samir Mather pointed out that actually
if we go back to that original picture
of straw meter and Vava
and and just follow what the string
theory tells you it tells you something
quite remarkable which is that all of
that stuff you use to build the black
holes out of these strings interacting
with membranes what have you if you
follow what those things do it tells you
that black holes really in some sense
are themselves emergent phenomena
they're not really real they are the
result of of taking the classical limit
and going to general relativity in some
sense and the floor I think emergent
phenomena are real yeah yes I tried to
shy away from the word fundamental and
lose you at 59 minutes yeah yeah
and so so that's all sounds a bit woolly
but the pragmatic result is that again
in a way it's maybe again a kind of a
duality if you're interested in
Astrophysical problems that are far away
from the business of quantum effects
sure use Einstein's general relativity
and that solution that schwa sholde
tortoise is the black hole with a
horizon and that'll that'll do a good
job if you're interested in under to
understanding the internal structure of
the black hole from a quantum mechanical
perspective that's not good enough yeah
and what and what this picture coming
from string theory tells you is that you
build black holes out of these these
fuzzy kinds of
domains that you can actually describe
in the string theory that they're in in
a way the stringiness makes it all very
fuzzy and when you put lots of them
together and sort of squint a little bit
it effectively looks like the thing you
call a black hole with it with a sharp
horizon but if you if you if you if you
look closely enough you'll see that
actually there is no horizon the horizon
just to this effective thing that
describes the collective phenomena
coming from all of those things
interacting together and and and in some
ways it mediately tells you that the
black hole information paradox isn't a
paradox at all it's just a paradox that
is forced upon you by taking that
approximation of pretending there's a
horizon effectively whether it really
isn't so speaking of the real world
we're in it as your professor and if you
go teach a class so I really wanted to
talk about the fact that you wrote a
graphic novel I had a little more time
oh you have a little more I'm not I'm
not too far away and and if your
students don't start turning up for at
least another few minutes after class so
you know how much time you have so I'll
mention it in the in the intro and tell
us a little bit because it comes out of
your desire to have everyone be
enthusiastic about physics and string
theory but you wrote a graphic novel and
you illustrated it yeah and you know in
some ways the the Illustrated and
graphic part of it wasn't the driving
force so much as as my frustration with
the fact that you know the kind of books
we write you know as sort of
professional theorists who want to tell
you exciting things about what we're
doing aren't always aren't always
inviting you to be part of the
conversation and what I really wanted to
do was was was have something that was
more conversational in some ways that it
didn't see it it didn't I don't want it
just to be the voice of the expert
telling you what to think about stuff
and there's nothing wrong with that kind
of book you don't survive you're gonna
listen do not read the comment and and
so and so I wanted to revisit in some
ways I realized that it would be fun to
revisit this ancient form which is the
dialogue forum where you
actually you as a reader you end up
eavesdropping on a conversation between
people about ideas and in some sense
that gives you multiple voices and
different points of view and it helps
you unpack the concepts in a way that I
think is not done as much as I think
would be nice in sort of contemporary
writing so that was the idea and then
I've had the ambition of writing a book
in dialogue form my publisher does not
want me to do it I think I'm working on
it uh-huh
it would not be illustrated but you
pulled it off so I'm jealous well you
know thank you and yes a lot of
publishers in fact most of them just
didn't get it right they didn't get what
I was trying to do they and and then
worse it had all these pictures because
then I thought because I was thinking I
actually would be really great would be
to see these conversations aren't you
know what we do think of the dialogues
going back to these ain't any of the
Ancients we think of people in togas on
mountaintops yeah having deep
conversations about philosophy and I
want us to go where we can have
conversations but they're taking place
in the contemporary world you know in
cafes and museums and on buses and
trains where we all are and and science
isn't just taking place in in labs and
conference rooms and what-have-you and
then the other thing was it would be
ordinary people and it would be great if
you could see these people in these
places so that was the whole package and
I thought oh clearly this would be
narrative art would be a graphic novel
style a book and they talking about
string theory and so they tow that
string theory is in there but you know
it isn't a book about string theory it
is one of many things that that people
talk about in these conversations the
other great thing about conversations is
that conversations don't have a signpost
telling you what it's about
right so one of the great things about
science is that it's interconnected
right and you start talking about one
thing and you end up in this other place
and it's all been interesting I mean
hopefully and and and and so that
messiness of conversation I also thought
it would be fun to have and then the
final thing and I uh
because I am sort of babbling is is the
fact that I think these conversations
really do happen i I'm a big people
watcher I sit in cafes and I end up
listening to people and science does
come up and you hear people you know
neither of them are experts but they
they want to engage with this stuff they
saw a TV show or they read a book and
they want to talk more about these ideas
and so in one of the things that's
frustrating is that no one celebrates
that these conversations are taking
place so I wanted the book that really
celebrates the spirit of those
conversations invites people to have
their own and gives you a snapshot of
some of those conversations through
through you know thumbing through and
seeing what's going on so that was the
idea yeah I seem to like they do have
they do happen these conversations and
they don't happen enough and we can
encourage them a little bit more and so
it's called the dialogues yes dialogues
subtitle conversations about the nature
of the universe available wherever books
are available where other books are
available and you know you'll find some
bookstores where it's in the science
section and some bookstores where it's
in the graphic novel section just asked
for it just as now and if they don't
have it tell them to order a bunch
because other people will find them and
usually really really love it once they
once they find it alright Clifford
Johnson thanks so much peanut butter
it's a real pleasure
[Music]
you
[Music]